- WELL, THAT'S INTOLERANT.
HOW WOULD YOU FEEL IF THEY
SAID BAD THINGS ABOUT YOU?
- THAT'S ALL THEY DO!
I KNOW BECAUSE...
I USED TO BE A MEMBER.
IT WAS 15 YEARS AGO.
I WAS YOUR AVERAGE,
EVERYDAY LITTLE GIRL.
[grunts]
I WANTED TO PLEASE
MY MOTHER SO MUCH.
[rip]
[girls giggling]
SHE JUST IGNORED ME
AND MY HANKERING FOR HOO HAA-ING
TILL SHE COULDN'T ANYMORE.
MY FATHER
AND THE CHURCH MEMBERS
MADE A "GAY CURING" MACHINE.
THEY CALLED IT
"THE HOMO ERADICATOR."
- YOU LIKE THAT, SINNER?
DO YOU?
I'LL BET SLATER
FROM SAVED BY THE BELL
WOULD MAKE YOU SCREECH.
- MMM...
- DOESN'T PAT SAJAK
HOLD YOUR GAY BACK?
- MMM...
- AND TRY ROMANCIN'
TED DANSON.
- MMM.
[slow beeping]
[rapid beeping]
[electrical buzzing]
- YOU HAD ENOUGH?
- NO.
I WANNA SEE HOW IT ENDS.
WHEN IT DIDN'T WORK,
MY PARENTS DISOWNED ME.
THEY BOUGHT A ST. BERNARD,
NAMED IT CONNIE,
AND PHOTOSHOPPED ME
OUT OF ALL THE FAMILY PICTURES.
I NEVER SPOKE
TO THEM AGAIN.
- MAN, THAT'S MESSED UP!
IF THEY WANTED
A DOG NAMED CONNIE,
THEY COULD'VE JUST KEPT YOU.
- SHUT UP, IDIOT.
CONNIE, I NEVER KNEW
YOU'D BEEN THROUGH SO MUCH.
WOODY, YOU CAN'T HAVE
THAT HATE-FILLED CHURCH HERE.
- YEAH, YEAH.
MAYBE I SHOULD RECONSIDER
HAVING THESE HATE-MONGERS
AT OUR PARK.
- THEY PAID CASH.
- CHA-CHING!
WELCOME, HATE MONGERS!
WE NEED TO MAKE
THESE PEOPLE FEEL COMFORTABLE.
TIME TO DE-GAY THE PARK!
CONNIE, PUT ON THIS DRESS.
YOW. THAT'S A TOUGH SELL.
HERE.
FOR THE NEXT 24 HOURS,
YOU'RE GONNA BE A STRAIGHT GUY
NAMED
CHESTER...BEEFBOTTOM.
- [groans]